so there's this saying in the
entrepreneurial world and that is don't
die today and that means try to keep the
lights on for one more day we're doing
this so why do you think so many
filmmakers don't make another film hmm
how do they get their first film made
and and then go on to their second and
then their third and then their fourth a
lot of them it seems like don't they
don't go past the first and I can
understand why they're tapped out
financially right exhausted they didn't
see it had the kind of distribution that
they wanted obviously yeah but you could
you could ask the same why do people
keep starting companies over and over
again and then go on to another one if
it doesn't work that's a really good
question yeah I think it's different for
everybody I think that there are people
that only have one movie in them you
know or that that in the making of the
movie they realized that that was enough
you know that that was enough I don't
need to make any more movies or want to
make any more movies but I think most
people who are you know genuine
filmmakers if they make a film
regardless of what happens whether it
did well or never with never got
distribution regardless what happens
you're you're constantly searching for a
route to make the next movie whatever it
is and so why they don't make a second
movie may just be like you said it could
be that they don't have the financial
means to make it independently that
perhaps they just maybe they've gone up
for jobs but didn't get them I mean I've
been up for millions of jobs that I
didn't get I don't know I have a lot of
empathy for filmmakers who don't get the
next movie made because I've been one of
them you know I just know what that's
like it's a very painful thing to really
want to work and make something and not
have the the means or maybe even the
psychological emotional foundation to
carry forward because there's a lot of
like you know there's a lot of damage
that gets done if it doesn't all work
out you know when it often most of the
time it doesn't so there has to be
something inside of you that
that somehow pushes you over all that
damage to make the next thing and I
think that those that of us that are
able to do that are lucky but I'm not
sure you know I'm not sure I just know
that there are a lot of people who want
to make movies that don't that don't get
a chance you think they feel like angry
that no one appreciated their work or is
it just why bother I think it's part of
it I think if you put yourself in if you
put your heart and soul in something and
nobody gives a you're gonna be you
know that the the tendency to be bitter
or disappointed or even broken is very
likely it's funny I remember hearing
something about marlon brando certainly
you know had a rich and varied career
and had no reason to complain but they
said there was a dividing line in his
work
it was everything before one-eyed jacks
which he directed his only the only
movie ever directed and after one-eyed
jacks they says personality after
one-eyed jacks was much more i don't
really give a because he talked
about how one-eyed jacks for him was
like he put everything into that movie
he wanted that movie which is the one
movie directed he probably wanted direct
more he wanted that to make a difference
and people at the time were like yeah
one-eyed jacks whatever and so he was
like well this then i don't
want to try and it i'm not gonna do
this again and he only gave this much
instead of this much whether that's true
or not i think it's understandable you
can get yeah you can get despondent and
you can get it's like you know not
wanting to if you had have been in a bad
relationship and you your hearts been
broken you're not gonna be like yeah i'm
gonna fall in love again you're kind of
like yeah maybe how you know you like so
there's a lot of gonna wait for that but
i think that if you've been hurt you're
gonna stop you know i know that again
like search and rescue has taken many
years for me to get at this point even
though I've been super lucky to be able
to work on a lot of different projects
over the years i hesitated putting this
into play because i knew i had to do it
myself that i had to do it in an
unorthodox manner that it wasn't
it's gonna be something that it was all
gonna be set up and I have I knew I had
to do everything and then that end of
itself is kind of like once you start to
pile up all the stuff that you have to
do that that in and of itself could stop
you
you know from taking that first step so
yeah I think that that any filmmaking
like any art is populated by a lot of
sensitive people cuz to do anything good
you have to have a certain degree of
sensitivity but that also you make makes
you vulnerable to the to what happens in
the real world when things don't go your
way and maybe those people feel it a
little bit more strongly and don't
bounce back as as readily maybe you
talked about dating and relationships
reminds me of going on a date like yeah
though alright I'll have coffee with
this person you're just like whatever
and then the person that you and you're
like I can't I can't even I want to be
able to speak he's right
so and and those are the projects you
want to work on but you're afraid
because you know what if it doesn't work
out right what if they break what if
what if what if the movie and ii was
like what if the movie breaks up with me
you know what I mean right that's really
what it is it's like I'm gonna put my
everything into this and what if the
movie dumps me you know which you know
is funny I never thought about it in
those terms but you know I mean all you
have to do is look at you know Terry
Gilliam and he's mrs. hits and really
dumb things lately which is like Jesus
Terry you're supposed to be the Freak
why are you saying these stupid things
but you know obviously Lawson limoges
there is the easiest way of of
representing that idea of going after
something with everything you've got and
then just to be sort of smited when
everything goes wrong and the movie
doesn't happen so that experience is
something that all filmmakers who've
been doing it for years know that
they've gotten is close or they may be
in that just as in that case we're
actually shooting and it fell apart so
the movie can break up with you and
that's a that can be devastating and
that can be reason enough not to like
start it not to get into another movie
relationship sure or you can make your
hearts of darkness and control mechanics
actly
and then you have two things that but
that's a rare instance that's true
that's true and I think he was you know
as clearly when you watch hearts of
darkness all he wanted was for that to
for him to fall off a pier and break his
legs or didn't have to finish the movie
so in that case he wanted out because he
thought he was it up so badly
and it just turned out that of course he
wasn't but yeah I think there when you
see documentary about about filmmakers
going through that that doubt and those
fears those are the healthiest
documentaries is not a lot of them but
those are the ones that I think that the
most beneficial to filmmakers and and
students because you understand that
it's not just oh these are professionals
that now they're there and they couldn't
possibly have self-doubt and they
couldn't possibly be racked with anxiety
it's like no it doesn't matter where you
are in your career you've you're always
if it matters feeling those feelings and
sometimes those feelings can be
overpowering you know you have to be
able to harness that and use it that
energy and some other way to get it done
but yeah we all feel that those
pressures and those those anxieties no
matter where you are whatever stage
you're right it's kinda like with Jim
Carrey with the Netflix at forgive me
I'm drawing a blank on yeah he was
willing to show write various things and
a lot of people I think aren't willing
to go there and I understand why yeah
and not everybody is at the level that
Jim Carrey is I think once you get to a
certain level then you can show all that
right you probably keep true you know or
but people are afraid people are afraid
to expose that for fear of losing what
you have that if people see that
vulnerability or that humaneness that
somehow it will contribute to the people
taking that away what you've what you've
striven for for so many years but yeah I
think those are the healthiest
documentaries for any filmmaker to see
you